or spot betting which is what where the
major money is playing the Rangers
Glasgow Derby and then they have a bet
after that on Celtic's next game against
Barcelona M and it was correct and I a
say 2,000 nothing to do with me I went
playing in the competition and this
somebody at Paddy Power picked up on
there give it to the Scottish fa
Scottish fa then give it to the fa the
fa then looked historically into the
better that I give them all me account
and said look this is what I've bet on
I'm I'm being transparent these are all
my accounts I've been bet on football I
shouldn't have been bet on football but
I'm a football addict I'm a football fan
like I want to try and predict football
it's the industry I know wa so they
kicked you out for that so they banned
me for 18 months and at the time they
had a 12 million pound sponsor on the
front of the England shirs with lad
Brooks the gambling partn so I'm like
this is hypocrisy